my chocolate boot design is perfect I
can't wait to make more chocolate hi
Willie wow that's a new balloomba I
would like to express my interest in
your business Enterprise Splendid I
represent the league of Oompa Loompas
and I am offering our goods and or
services and I would like to pay you a
fair wage that is of special importance
to me as I do not like hazardous working
environments I don't care about money I
care about chocolate can we live in your
factory and get paid in chocolate what
no no there will be a separate housing a
separate from the factory independent
areas where you will live have good
houses uh there will be no OSHA
violation splendid
now I can help you try to murder some
kids if you want great let's sing a
silly song about